a breakthrough today in one of the many
criminal and civil cases connected to
former president Trump one of his
closest business partners the former CFO
of the Trump organization appears set to
plead guilty to 15 counts of Fraud and
tax evasion he could potentially testify
about closely guarded business practices
and this comes as the former president
also faces scrutiny for his actions
leading up to the January 6 right and
for possibly mishandling classified
material Catherine Herridge is following
all of this for us in Washington
Catherine good morning
good morning Vlad there will be Court
action from New York to Florida Today
where a judge will consider a request
from media organizations including CBS
news on whether key pieces of evidence
should be made public in the FBI search
of Mar-A-Lago
as the legal battle over the
steel-sealed affidavit moves to this
Florida courthouse the federal probe and
a former president Trump's alleged
handling of top secret documents taken
to his Mar-A-Lago home remains under
scrutiny the search warrant shows three
federal laws are in play including the
alleged unauthorized taking disclosure
or destruction of government records
later today the judge will consider if
law enforcement documents that justified
the FBI search should be made public the
justice department claims releasing the
affidavit could serve as a road map to
the government's ongoing investigation
future cooperation by Witnesses and harm
other high-profile investigations
a second criminal probe is unfolding in
Georgia where Rudy Giuliani the former
president's personal lawyer and
long-time friend appeared before a
special grand jury Wednesday after he
was subpoenaed so I was very happy that
I satisfied my obligation prosecutors
are exploring whether Trump or his
allies violated Georgia's election laws
when they allegedly tried to overturn
the state's 2020 presidential election
results
and in recent weeks grand jury subpoenas
suggest Federal investigators are
examining key White House meetings
leading up to the deadly Capital Riot
former vice president Pence said
Wednesday he might answer questions from
the January 6th committee if there was
an invitation to participate I would
consider it the Trump organization is
also at the center of a long-running
investigation in New York my Chief
Financial Officer Alan weiselberg
and you think George is tough when you
see Alan Alan weisselberg could plead
guilty as early as today in the ledge
tax scheme to compensate Trump
organization Executives off the books
impleading guilty weisselberg has to
acknowledge conspiring with the Trump
organization to evade taxes and he could
be called to testify if the case goes to
trial Trump maintains his innocence and
says these investigations Tony are
politically motivated
Catherine Herridge with the overview for